how's it going ladies and gentlemen
we're up to the next episode of design
patterns and this one is going to be
about the flyweight pattern now what the
flyweight pattern is for is for
basically saving memory and space so
essentially well let's just go ahead and
do an example i'm going to make a new
folder here
we'll call it flyweight
and we're going to bring in well we're
going to one of these cmake files and
we're going to make a main to actually
run the code at the end when we're done
typing it up and i think that's all
we're going to need here let's rename
these
let's actually start out with the front
end code here and kind of walk through
it so essentially if you're reusing an
object that
maybe has some properties sometimes you
don't want to reinstantiate that object
over and over and in that case you would
just keep referring to the same one and
maybe apply some properties over it if
you need to such as well for it in game
let's think about
what if you want to place a bunch of
grass on the ground but you don't want
it to like overload all your processes
it's like processing all this grass just
killed my frame rates type of thing you
don't want that to happen so in games
this is often used for terrain repeating
grass repeating bushes stuff like that
but it could really apply to anything
that has a lot of shared properties
all right so let's uh let's just dive in
here real quick let's make an ant main
and let's say that we want to make a
world of
random grass and first you know in a
real generator thing it might be a
little better we're just going to like
make a a big block of grass so we'll
just make like a 10 by 10 of little
grasses
little grasses that sounds funny uh and
i
so we'll just do this simple pattern to
go 10 deep and we'll put another loop in
that so just straight forward little
loop there
and in here we'll just place grass so
we'll just say place grass all right or
maybe it'll be render grass or something
it just you know this could be done in a
while loop if you're in some game logic
and drawing or something but it just
depends for now we're just going to
place grass and get a sample of it and
yeah that's always the trouble with
these tutorials is people have uh
different experiences we'll say with
their code so sometimes people have a
little trouble adapting one pattern to
what they're really doing and i try to
branch that a little bit or cover that
bridge that i guess i try to bridge that
and
it's often very hard and uh it basically
makes me think in a way that often once
again becomes confusing because i'm
trying to go too broad so i don't know
what i'm getting to other than we're
going to keep it simple but i also
want you to know that this is just a
simple goofy example in reality it could
always be in a lot of scenarios
not this isn't the only way to do it
right all right but the concept of
reusing an object and not
reinstantiating that's the big thing
with this pattern if that all makes
sense to you already you're probably
good but if you're still a little
confused i'll show you okay so say we
want to place grass at i j
that simple now when we place this grass
how does this function work that's where
it's going to come in it's the exact
same function we could assume to start
the graph is all exactly the same so
anytime we call this function we don't
want to recreate the grass and then do
it yet again so let's make a flyweight
of it we're going to add a new file call
it uh we'll just call it grass placer
flyweight put the word flyweight in
there although you don't actually
normally do that in code or in your
project it's just because this is an
example uh
so let's make our place grass function
and it takes into i j alright and what
else how else could we can improve this
well there's a ton of things we can do
let's just actually place grass we'll
just see out it for now because we don't
have any form of display other than a
terminal so i guess we gotta ask we
gotta put things in the terminal to show
that it's working
but if you have something else
of course you adapted how you need to
helps to have quotations around your
code of strings i guess this would be
characters okay so now we just need to
think of an object here
that is actually the grasp it's no
object just to see out
include io stream so it actually makes a
little more sense when you have some
object you're referencing in theory this
would be referencing a block of the
grass so it would be something like this
and maybe it has uh a location of x and
y we'll just call it lope2 and we'll
initialize that to zero zero
as we're assuming a 2d world just for
simplicity's sake
so this would be
like the overhead
brass overhead because the actual
details of the grass where it's located
in memory
we don't necessarily need to reuse that
but we could apply properties to say a
shader or to say how it's drawn to a
geographic layer and all that really
needs is a
a model view or a model matrix rather
so the overhead would be the model
matrix sure you're going to need a bunch
of different model matrixes for where
they all are located we're just in this
case going to represent that as slope 2
for an x and y
but the actual grass itself you don't
need to reinstantiate and maybe have
some other things like color or gradient
that you use as an overhead but that
would be the overhead per item so if you
have that many in the world the only
thing you need is this overhead you
wouldn't actually need a bunch of these
the grasses
because this would be like uh
yeah this would be like the grass
instantiation here so it would look
something like let's make it static so
it only implements once
it's going to like this code but we'll
have something like an unsigned int
raw location and like unsigned and or i
don't know this is just i'm assuming
opengl stuff like number of elements so
that's
once this is uploaded then
you don't need to re-upload it and
that's be careful about
and this would be like uh
code to upload your model
details to
graphics memory presumably so i could
put this for example in my engine and
that's how i would do it if i had a
grass class
as i would basically just do something
like this
upload uh i guess delete is a keyword
use here because the keyword will
capitalize and since this is static and
it's already instantiated
this should instantiate
when we uh
start the program
let's be sure to put like pragma once
here
or
include fragment
and then this delete code to remove from
graphics
and when we do this we need some sort of
flag to say it's already instantiated
like uh
well draw location is a zero we know
that's invalid so we would say some we
could just do something like this if
draw a loc uh
it's not well if it equals zero then do
the upload
autocorrect you only help me when it
actually you don't need you i don't know
and for the delete we only want to run
that after all location is not equal to
zero means it's set
so this way
you'd only have to instantiate it once
and then when you go to draw it this is
already done it doesn't matter how many
times you need to render this graph you
don't need to go instantiate it again
and that's essentially the flyweight is
that part of it the part that you don't
need to instantiate again the only thing
you're going to need to instantiate is a
bunch of locations which is way cheaper
than doing this upload and managing that
of course it's going to be more and it
depends on the number who knows how many
elements it has how many triangles i
guess grass isn't going to be huge but
it'll add up once you make a bunch of
them however you don't need to store
every single one of those you just need
to store it once and reuse it so i'm
kind of i'm be i feel like i'm beating a
dead horse with this concept so i hope
that that makes sense but let's let's do
the example to be super sure that it's
making sense go back to our main real
quick and let's just make a vector let's
do something like this
okay so instead of place grass let's uh
make grass locations so we'll just let's
do global now just pretend that this is
the main front end for your game or
whatever we'll make a standard vector
of uh
okay now we're gonna get a little
complicated with uh this location too we
need to like type that that right
type death
brass overhead or well
this isn't as easy and uh c plus plus as
it is in other languages
because you can't just go like
into two just doesn't work
because you can't have it over here you
gotta have it after the variable name so
we have to come up with a bit of a
different solution and we could just use
a pair or we could
put more code in front of this to make
it even more
uh
robust or we could use the glm library
and use their back to essentially we
need a vec2 to be a pointer of two uh
two elements
uh just so that we can put it in this
vector so it's actually you know this
gets complicated pretty quickly it's uh
it'd actually just be easier i'm kind of
going over some maybe different thought
processes you could have but essentially
you just want to split it and destruct
any easier
to go about this way we could just
literally use this
grass overhead and put it right there in
that vector of course we need to include
the header so i'm talking about
grass place or fly weight vector of
grass overhead
uh and we'll call it grasses it's a
weird word to say grasses all right and
we'll just do grasses.you know push
back
and well we need our object which is
grass overhead dot x and y right we need
to so we're gonna need to put one of
those that's our overhead
uh we'll just call temp and we'll
instantiate it with i and j so that
shortcut should work in older versions
so c plus plus uh you might not be able
to instantiate it so easily like that
but it should be fine here and then
we'll push back
so we've run that a bunch of times and
we get all our grass locations zero
through ten on the x and y's and then
when later when we go to draw uh
say running so while running
we might do something like uh
i don't know for example graphics
layer roll
and it would be i don't know maybe we
have a i guess in reality this would
have the draw would be something like
this
so you know use draw pass in this of
course you'd want to do this as a const
reference to uh make it a little more
efficient so
and some of these others could be
improved too probably i'm kind of
overlooking a lot of it but it's a
little more important once you get to
draw because this is going to be ran a
ton every frame right so you definitely
want to make this one as efficient as
possible and uh so then we just use this
instant
grass incident
and then we need the grass overhead so
we would basically go through this and
uh draw it
each one
and we can use some recent c plus plus
features to just const auto this
and go through each grasses so each
grass and grass is
hope you guys actually enjoy these code
from scratch versions uh
hopefully it like you know helps it
click better than just reading a web
page but we'll go over an example after
this off of some web page and just walk
through it and do some uh analyzing and
just see what we think but for now let's
finish our grass we're pretty much done
i've already gone through the concepts
just want to finish up the code for now
or at least temporary code no so the
draw
is we're just going to say grass at or
something for now and this would be
tails dot x scales dot y
but what you really do here is you would
uh set what you would really do in a
render the
set shader with details run draw on the
grass
so that's what you would really do but
instead we're just going to say grasshad
to you know okay let's go back here uh
what do we need we need to put grass in
here there we go
this grass instant knocking scene yeah i
guess not so they might not i might be
doing something syntactically wrong here
with the static construct
like that
but we can do it like this and this is
fine as long as we don't multi include
this header it's gonna should be fine
so we essentially have this one class
that's already instantiated but we do
need to make sure it gets uploaded
um and that that's something you'd have
to handle so you might want to do that
before that you would just go like uh
grass instant dot
upload it might be like an init this
case uploads just one way of saying i
guess let's change this to an and that
that should do maybe this would be like
instead of delete d init or whatever you
call it just call it d and hit to d
initialize it would look something more
like this there you go
so as you can see as with the core you
know we uh
it doesn't necessarily matter what order
you do these hints also doesn't
necessarily need to be global this could
all be moved down here and it'd be fine
got to declare this vector before we
start filling it out though that's one
thing
so however you want to do that wherever
you want to put that but this code would
all need to happen before we start our
loop so the the core concept here is
basically that we only init this graph
once but yet we draw it a whole bunch of
times and the only thing we replicate is
the things that are actually different
not this core code so use that as you
may for terrain that's where it's
generally used where you commonly see it
as an obvious example is just terrain
and games with the repeating stuff and
of course they don't have one they might
have like five different instances but
even still with five you can randomly
place them and still get some variety
and it will look like a lot more than
five different ones or feel like a lot
more so there you go hope that makes
sense we should be able to run this code
now uh
and let me put a few more little just
things in here
uh to make it a little clearer all right
there we go got a little bit of
additional comments in there so people
might understand if they're just
browsing and finding this code somehow
okay so we'll say grass is a knit and
then we will also do an ever important
thing of making the straw location no
longer zero so it would actually be uh
whatever it would be like a val is what
you usually call them a vertex array
object uh but we're just gonna set it to
one for now and your graphics layer
would determine all that and how many
elements you know that's just how many
triangles basically this would also be
set to whatever properly by the submit
but we're not even using it so i'm just
going to kind of ignore it actually i'm
just going to even delete it to make it
more simple
but that's something you typically use
too when you're uploading models all
right so grass in it and so the else
would be like already and they don't do
it again but we're just going to leave
that off but essentially we want this
guard to make sure we don't initialize
it
and same thing here i would set it back
to 0
and grass unit
and i'll put this uh same similar code
now we don't need this plate brass that
was just my sample starting point but
there you go i think we've done enough
here let's give it a run let me make
sure all the cmakes are fixed up i think
i need to add flyweight here and then we
should see it show up helps to spell
correctly all right there it goes okay
once the cmake generation finishes we
should see in our list here if you're
using cmake just follow standard cmake
procedures you'll see this executable
when you're out after the build
but of course
in case it's not obvious i'm using
visual studio's built-in cmake stuff to
uh
help out and kind of uh
reduce the number of the amount of
terminal code we need to type but it's
essentially doing it in the background
all right so let's run our flyweight
make sure we get uh what we expect like
we have a few warnings i just spelled
some things incorrectly not a big deal
okay let's try again
oh this uh grass overhead needs to be
before the grass or else it doesn't
understand what it is and also of course
this would have more this would have
like rgb color you know a lot more it's
i'm just keeping it real simple just
want to reiterate that uh we are missing
a few things here what are we missing
okay yeah i
just need to correct some code here i
believe it's
this one it's going to make sure we
spell these right in this grass instant
it's just a dot
all right so there we go now it should
work there we go we got grass in it and
we should get at some point oh it's
going to infinitely run here
so that's a little confusing but when it
calls this drawl it should be spitting
out something yeah it should be spinning
out this grass drawn at
but it seems to be getting stuck in the
init let's take a look what's going on
oh
this code right here this should be a j
it's just staying stuck in this loop
all right j's eyes yep all right and
there we go it's uh this is where it's
drawing the grass and rather than
displaying it on a screen we're just
putting the location on a console all
right now let's go google a few examples
and see what they have online just to
see how you might see uh other examples
we're over at uh refactoring.guru they
seem to have pretty good versions of a
lot of these so if you get stuck highly
recommend reading through their articles
also known as cash that sounds about
right so here is the uh we'll just read
their quick intent section because i
think this summarizes it very good
flyweight is a structural design pattern
that lets you fit more objects into the
available amount of ram by sharing
common parts of state between multiple
objects instead of keeping all the data
on each object there we go that's i feel
like that's pretty straightforward and
it looks like they got some examples of
it here let's see what we can find i
want to find some code or some pseudo
code here we go let's look at the
pseudocode so we got a class of a tree
type it's got a name color texture and
constructor and draw alright we got a
tree factory that has some static fields
so this one is probably going to be the
flyweight two static fields got tree
types all the different types you can
get tree type you pass in a color
texture name color and texture and it
creates it and returns the type
and looks like it also adds it and then
we got just a class of tree which has an
x and y probably for location kind of
like we were doing
and it has a very similar draw kind of
like we were doing to i didn't look at
this example before my example i swear
it's just coincidence but uh you know in
a 3d world this would be xyz
so keep that in mind all right and then
we got forest which has
all a bunch of different trees and it's
got they made a method of plant trees
that uses the plant or the tree factory
to make a bunch
and then draw a bunch so some of these
things you can see are not going to be
reinstantiated mainly once as this adds
tree types
it's only setting up a
name color and texture it's not redoing
this whole canvas and all of that
because essentially they don't really
say it here but this color and texture
are going to be sent to the shader or
whatever is determining the draw which
is going to be a whole separate process
that the
making of the trees now there's
something here that actually is a little
confusing to me that i don't oh i see
it's fine
okay this is really important that's
what i was looking for that i missed
over this find right here checks
uh if
the tree already exists okay very
important so
we would assume that find is null if it
doesn't already exist so when you factor
a tree and give it a name color and
texture
if it already is found then we just
return the type if it's not found we're
going to add it and then return the type
so essentially as we add trees we're
going to
develop a whole bunch of them but if it
tries to do the same one twice it will
just not it'll just skip that
with this here and not make a new tree
and instead reuse whatever found so
that's where the flyweight comes in
right there on the tree factory so
that's pretty cool i like that example i
do something very similar in some of my
code on archer engine for a lot of the
graphics stuff so it's very useful in
that area all right well
hope you guys enjoyed the video don't
forget to uh like comment subscribe if
you want to go the extra mile you can uh
drop a donation or something somewhere
or sign up on one of the pages have a
patreon with all kinds of tiers there's
some stuff here on youtube do have a
discord you can find links to all this
stuff over on my youtube main page so if
you click on my little code tech
tutorials logo somewhere you should get
to that i appreciate all of you guys
that support and help out it really does
mean a lot and it does help me keep
going i'll see you guys in the next
episode and uh this code will be up on
github link below too peace out guys
[Music]